The jogan Experience huberman gets into
all that Academia there's tons of
studies on this so and and all I think
the main reason it's not adopted more
often
is they're just in the insurance model
right they they use the tool that's in
their tool belt and if that's not a tool
in my tool belt then I'm not going to
talk about it and I don't have time to
do it and uh and that's where I see
large language models and an evolving
Market allowing patients to get that
education on their own they don't have
to wait to talk to a doctor right I will
have a team of academics right there at
your fingertips proactively analyzing
everything about you and I would tell
you another I talked about predictive
proactive personalized all that another
one would be
private private you do not want this
data in the hands of insurance companies
listen to what Gary Breco is telling you
he worked for the big insurance
companies he worked to assess your all
cause mortality risk and the risk
profile to the insurance company right
and so if you if let's just say in a in
a miracle world all the sudden uh Blue
Cross Blue Shield rolls out a large
language model to streamline your
experience and they want to tie into
your wearables the last person you want
digging through your underwear drawer is
the insurance company because they're
going to use it to limit your care to
limit what they C
and to kick you off a plan right they're
going to know when the chronic disease
is coming and they're going to charge
you when they know they can monetize you
and then as soon as you reach a state
where they can't and that's the
dangerous side of these large language
models and that's the dangerous side of
the tool and so a a sword in the right
hands is you know one thing and a sword
in the wrong hands is a whole another
thing
Jesus I wonder if they are trying to do
that I wonder if these insurance
companies are they're for sure going to
roll that out yeah if they're not
already and that's the problem like when
you have an insurance-based model and
that's where I would tell you maintain
the car outside of the system right and
the insurance-based large language
models are going to ensure that you stay
on these treatments because that's where
they're profitable correct so there's
the insurance company and then we we
broke this down last time then there's
the pharmacy benefit manager Pharmacy
benefit managers are middleman between
the insurance companies and big Pharma
okay and they were put in place to
negotiate the price of pharmaceutical
drugs for the average American because
so many drugs were coming into the
marketplace the government couldn't get
to and decipher what drugs make sense
what drugs don't make sense what should
we cover what should we not cover so
they allowed Pharmacy benefit managers
to do that within a decade the big
insurance companies went out and
acquired Pharmacy benefit managers
within a decade from that date the
pharmacy benefit managers began to
negotiate rebates to themselves not
discounts to the patient okay so yeah
that's that's where I was trying to go
with this when I talked about 244
million in fraud um in the state of Ohio
how where's the fraud and and the answer
is the margins are made in the mystery
the more confusing the insurance
companies can make it and the more
conduted they can make it the more
profits they can make they have only a
handful of levers they can to make money
so let's go over that they can raise
your co-pay they can raise your
deductible they can raise your
out-of-pocket expense that's one lever
they can drive down the price of a drug
that they buy at a wholesale price point
they can mark up the coverage of your
care for your
employer okay and then they tier price
all the pharmacy benefit manager gives a
tier pricing that tier pricing is not
based on what drug is best for you it is
based on what drug is best for their
financials and so they prioritize drugs
in a tier pricing under the misnomer to
the American people that a tier one drug
is the best drug and a tier four drug is
not as good right but the truth is a
tier four drug is not as profitable
because there's a lesser rebate and so
so let's say let's go back to the
insulin example the average price of
this insulin is $381 is what the Senate
uh finance committee found $381 on I
can't remember if it's santae I think
was their uh was their price out of that
the pharmaceutical company got less than
$40 so that remaining $0 something
dollars stayed at the pharmacy benefit
manager okay Pharmacy benefit managers
are making billions upon billions of
dollars a year they decide what gets
covered what goes on your insurance plan
what your co-pay is what your deductible
is and they can move any Leverage at any
time so examples let's go back to gp1s
right the uh the weight loss diabetes
medications those are showing up on
insurance plans as tier four with a
really high price tag well you look at
that and you go man wouldn't insurance
companies want to get rid of that
because it's cost them a lot no because
they're showing that the price of a glp1
is
$1,300 they never paid
$1,300 they paid a fraction of that but
then they go to the patient and they say
hey this is a tier four drug you have a
50% co-pay on this drug
$500 okay so they made their money there
they made their money off the rebate
from Big Pharma then they come the
patient pays more than they actually are
paying for the drug correct that is what
happens on most drugs and that is why I
built a compounding pharmacy and that's
but even if they don't let's say it's a
drug that you think is covered okay
maybe they maybe the the pharmacy
benefit manager got it wrong a drug
entered the market they didn't know it
was going to be a blockbuster they miss
missed miscalculated how this was going
to play out they have lever after lever
they can pull okay high margin drugs
they've gone out and bought pharmacies
so they own mail order pharmacies and
they so what they'll do like when I
owned a pharmacy Blue Cross Blue Shield
they literally said they owed me over a
million dollars for one month of
shipping out drugs I'd already shipped
all the drugs to their patient I'd
already done everything they come in and
say yeah we're not going to pay you we
don't think you collected the co-pays or
deductibles okay we did here's all the
records I can show you how soon can you
get an auditor out we want to cooperate
like we're a small company we need this
money oh it's three months before we can
get to you okay and then they begin to
make it so hard for you to survive in
their insurance model and then you'll be
sitting there and a couple months later
knock on the door hey man man her is
tough out there for these small
pharmacies you know we're looking to
acquire pharmacies just like you right
they've gobbled up the lifeblood of
America they've put all these smalles
out of business they now own most of
these big Juggernaut pharmacies so even
if CVS says we only made $10 off that
prescription what did the pharmacy
benefit manager make okay or what is the
pharmacy your mail order pharmacy making
lever after lever after lever then the
last part of it is my buddy who has Ms
he his his MS treatment I think is
$14,000 a month we just met I have
26 something employees across both
organizations we met with the insurance
company they're raising our rates
because they claim they paid $144,000 a
month for his drug right he had a huge
out- of-pocket burden on that drug but
was happy because he thought well hey
man it was going to be 14 and I only had
to pay
X and then they never paid the 14
because they negotiated a rebate on the
back end and then they turn around and
they mark up my insurance plan for all
my employees every year year after year
it is a profit driven system not a
patient outcome driven system and so
that's that's all I'm trying to hammer
home with patients when you say why
don't you take insurance because
insurance is the Crux of the problem you
cannot operate in that ecosystem and
provide quality Care
you can't everything's controlled
everything's dictated it's it's it's
terrible and most people have no
understanding or awareness of this so
there's no real push to fix this system
there's no real push to regulate and
analyze all these problems and what's
the downstream effect of these problems
yeah and I even hear clinicians talk a
lot of clinicians don't know like a lot
of clinicians don't even know about
Pharmacy benefit managers the the only
reason I know is because I've been in
every aspect of this business and I've
and then I would get into it and I go oh
oh God that's why that was happening
okay now I get it now I get the magic
trick I understand what you're doing
here how you're moving and shifting
profits and monetizing disease States so
think about this if I can monetize your
diabetes why would I cure or prevent
your
diabetes right and and I know if I'm a
bigwig at United or siga that you're
going to switch jobs in 3 years and by
the time that diabetes leads to
metabolic disease and a Cascade effect
that puts you in a hospital that cost me
more money you're somebody else's
problem or if I can stall it long enough
you're the federal government's problem
and so every aspect of healthc care is
focused on that quarter on that on on
that time frame um another terrible
example of surgery and this is honest to
God I talked to my buddy who's a
president at an orthopedic company he
told me he was sitting down with a
surgery center about joints and there's
a new joint that they have and it's more
expensive but the efficacy data of the
longterm benefits on it astronomically
outperform the other joint that this
hospital system was using he sat down
with the CEO of the hospital and he said
here's the data uh five years out here's
what we're seeing da da da d da the CEO
said I don't give a what happens 5
years out swear to God he's this is a
call I had yesterday he said he looked
me in the eye rum and he said if you
told me that this joint will last at
least 90 days and it's cheaper that's
all I care about oh my God because all
of their data and records and
accountability are only on the first 90
days once you're out of that 90day and
you've done your your little review and
all that you're off again and you're no
longer a monetizable patient and so too
when we talk about primary cares and
what's happened the same thing with
pharmacies where they've been gobbled up
by insurance companies if they're in the
insurance model is the same thing that
happened with primary care practices the
day of a primary care being independent
and a free thinker is over they're
employed by Hospital Systems major
conglomerates have gone out and bought
up the primary care practice why because
now that have the patient population if
I can get you at the primary care level
then I can control the referral of where
that Primary Care sends you as we
profiteer off your disease State okay so
you go to a primary care let's say let's
just walk through the same example I
gave earlier a methyl folate test they
never run that test right there's
genetics the methyl folate test tells me
my genetics but there's
epigenetics the choices I make every day
impact which genes turn on and which
genes turn off if nobody ever has a
conversation with me in my 30s about my
hormone levels about getting into the
sun about eating right and you push me
towards chronic disease because you
wrote me a prescription to treat a
symptom and now I go through this system
and I get
cancer that Primary Care is going to
refer me to an oncologist and that
oncologist is part of that same system
right and most people don't know this
65% of an oncologist income comes from
chemotherapy from the markup they're
making off your chemotherapy 65% and I I
attached that link Jamie too uh where it
it talks about this so all I'm getting
at is Russell bran said this and he was
spot on another guy who's not a
clinician but understood what's going on
here if we make things about profit
profs and quarterly earnings and big
business and not patient outcomes don't
be shocked when we get phenomenal
quarterly earnings and piss poor patient
outcomes 65% 65 and I attached the link
just so we'd have it so they have a
financial
incentive so this is an article where
they were trying to in uh the insurance
companies were trying to incentivize
them to use a generic in this instance
because this is one of those issues
where there's no rebate and no way for
the insurance company to monetize it but
it breaks down how much money these guys
65% of an oncologist income comes from
that wow this is incredible um and and
so I I say all this again because I
don't think that a clinicians to blame I
don't think that they're just operating
in the system that they're given they're
playing with the playing field that's
been set before them and the rules of
the game that have been set before
them